follow in a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany and my
guest today is a very special woman
indeed she's a journalist a philosopher
and writer who reports reflects and
write with great passion and originality
on themes that include war and war
crimes cultural identity and terrorism
suffering and speechlessness dance and
desire and much much more besides here
she is in person Carolyn Inka thank you
very much for joining us here today on
talking German it's wonderful to have
you here it's a pleasure now I could
list some or all of the universities
that Carolyn has been attached to the
prizes that she's won the publications
that she's written for but I think the
most important thing to tell you is this
that Carolyn emka is an explorer and
explorer of both the real and the
imaginary worlds and I'm sure she is
going to be a fascinating guest Karolina
just described you as an explorer how do
you describe yourself used that but I'm
a traveler I would say that would be
correct and indeed I think I would
describe wonderful ease that enjoy
traveling and exploring other countries
but also the imaginary landscapes of
literature or theory exactly that's that
that's the fascinating thing about you
that you you do you explore these very
real places that have maps that have
borders that have conflicts and then you
explore the world of the imagination
tell me where the two come together well
I think every trip that you make every
country that you travel to already I
mean it's already on your mind prior to
going so there is an imaginary landscape
there's an imaginary map that I have
before traveling to Iraq or Gaza or
Afghanistan and of course they match at
the moment when you arrive and you
realize that it's not at all what I
thought it was like they match I think
also in the narration of the people that
I talk to you
the way they remember the past the way
they dream and hopeful better future
there is also always this imaginary
realm and I think it is as important to
see in witness that as to see in witness
you know what's happening in a country
that's haunted by war and violence
you initially trained I think that's the
word to use as a philosopher and you've
become a ok you learned something decent
you learned philosophy yeah you came
from a source of a very well established
middle-class background I think it's
fair to say you know why philosophy did
your parents not put pressure on you to
study medicine or the law or something
like that um actually my father hadn't
studied at all so I think first of all I
had to establish that I would study I
think that was scary enough and then the
fact that I wanted to study philosophy
evidently um you know wasn't to the
great joy of my father and my mother I
think very early realized that I was
happy when reading books and as a
wonderful mother all my mother wanted
was that this slightly bizarre child
would be happy so she approved whatever
I wanted to do and follow very very
closely than my studies okay so the
books led to philosophy the philosophy
then led on to journalism I know you
still do philosophy you write philosophy
you teach philosophy you talked about
your travels and your encounters with
people now what what becomes clear to me
when I look at your career so far is
that you've you've confronted yourself
an awful lot with war zones with areas
of conflict with with suffering and
dislocation why specifically that why
have you confronted yourself with all
this just some extent I mean not to
sound rude I mean one reply would be why
not I I find it slightly strange that
nowadays people are surprised
when you make a decision to lead a life
that is dedicated to the lives of others
okay but then why not but then you write
about it what are you trying to achieve
by writing about it I think the I think
the first moment is it's just it's a
more reflex it's an impulse it's nothing
special I just see like any other you
know person who watches television I see
images of people suffering people in
need I happen to have the fashion that
is you know able to finance a trip to
these areas I happen to have a gift that
is describing what I see and forming it
into language and then I think one of
the key experiences that I think every
war reporter has made and I'm sure every
war reporter could say the same is that
whenever you travel to refugee camp then
you speak to victims of violence of you
know victims of exclusion what they do
is they don't beg you for practical help
they don't back for money they don't
back for you know taking them with you
but they beg you to write that down
they beg you to write down that story so
I think I never ever questioned what I'm
doing after the first such experience
the first time I was in a refugee camp
in Albania during the Kosovo crisis and
people were asking me to give testimony
of what they were suffering it was it
was without doubt that this is what I
would be doing for as long as I would be
allowed to do it
what a life great life so far much more
to come
I'd like to go back to your early days
and a couple of years ago two years ago
you published a book called how we
desire yeah which I read and it made a
great impression on me I have to say and
almost in a sort of inner in a relative
clause in that book almost in passing
you talks about having difficulties at
home when when you were a youngster and
I don't want to pry until you know what
happened when you when you were a child
a child but I would like to ask you the
question were you were you were handful
for your parents were you a rebel think
what you don't ask that question to my
father no I don't know if I was a rebel
that I mean yeah III guess intellectuals
you know enjoy presenting themselves as
the great rebels I know I don't think I
was but I think I was a bit too serious
probably for the taste of my father and
I think he rather had the idea that I
don't know and that women and books did
not necessarily belong to the same world
let's put it mildly we're back on the
theme of books here yeah I'm gonna go
see your book that was here was I mean
if I may and one thing I think it was
definitely more about the question of
intellectuality or sophistication or the
juhi of of reading than about
homosexuality so it that wasn't the the
big contentious issue it was really more
about yeah I think my father was worried
that I don't know I think that people
who read weren't necessarily good human
beings in his understanding in the book
that I just mentioned there is one
passage and again this was when I read
the book it was one of those passages
one of those lines that I underlined
there's a scene when you were at school
and a young boy a teenage boy is being
maltreated by some other boys you're
nodding you know the scene
a teacher involved as well which makes
it all the worse and you're sort of on
the fringe of this scene and you don't
intervene and the sentence goes
something like I will never let this
happen again I will never let something
like this go unsaid again I will bear
witness that was a very important moment
for you yeah it's tragic I would say
there's been other other moments I think
that we all remember from going to
school is where kids were being
stigmatized or excluded or mocked or
mistreated by others I mean there's this
this is you know really really
unfortunate way of including some and
excluding others that we all I think
experience in different rituals and this
particular scene was one scene where one
boy was being mistreated and I think at
the in the situation it wasn't quite
clear whether it was just fun or whether
it was already violence I thought it was
definitely abuse I thought so at the
time I thought it was horrific and yet I
didn't intervene I just walked away I
was disgusted and I never forgave myself
you were speechless that's too bad I was
speechless I was I think also shot I
missing I was to some extent probably
really shocked at what was happening and
I think the shock led to my inability to
act mean to just act and I you know
every one never knows whether one
would have this happen to oneself again
or not but I just hope that you know
that I don't stand by a couple of years
let's move on just a little bit and I
think 1989 I think you were not you were
22 years old and a shocking event in
your life for that Alfre housing then
chairman of Deutsche Bank was killed in
an inner terror attack by the Red Army
Faction he was a very close friend of
your family he was somebody who was very
important to you you viewed him as
effectively a godfather for you that too
had a very great impression on you and I
sense led to your lifelong preoccupation
with violence and what do you do with
the the use of the exercising of
violence yes and no I think you're
you're absolutely right it too had an
enormous effect I mean you know a person
you never don't you know whom you love
is is murdered by a terrorist group by
the way I mean I mean who's actors were
never found
I mean nobody was ever indicted for that
crime we still don't know who committed
this crime
which is indeed haunting for the whole
life because somehow you can't really
imagine and you can't come to terms with
it anyway but you I think it
particularly can't come to terms with it
if the perpetrators were never Leslie
Shay is there's no closure there can be
no pungent I mean there is a new closure
I think so in that sense you're right I
mean that was a transformative dramatic
loss the Occupy or the preoccupation
with violence I don't I think that
existed prior to this attack I think in
my case it has one very very simple
banal roots probably in my character is
I just can't stand injustice and it's
very very banaue and nothing special
moral of reflex or impulse just to
respond to passin in need you know full
stop
damn that's quite simple but the other
one I think is I'm a German
and I'm you know of a post-war
generation that hasn't experienced war
in my lifetime in Germany but whose
entire moral and political formation had
one reference point in that was the
shore and the reflection on National
Socialism and I think if you ask me
about what is sort of you know the motif
or the impulse behind traveling to war
zones and carrying about victims of
violence I think it's much more informed
and yeah emotionally nurtured I think by
this sense of responsibility for this
heritance
you knew her and you need ring house now
you were friends III believe what can
you tell us about her great loss for
everyone who knew her but I think also
for the public who could know her but
someone new maybe a little bit through
the images she was an extremely
passionate wonderfully funny also person
with a great love for Afghanistan which
is what makes this murder of house
in Afghanistan said tragic I mean you
would say if somebody kills somebody
else you know it's a so it's wrong but
in this case it was totally absurd
mm-hmm did you you you must have talked
to her about the kind of dangers that
ultimately led to her death and the kind
of dangers that you and her will have
found yourselves entity actually we
didn't talk about that at all because I
think we was way out I think because it
was such a part of our lives that I
think it was much less an issue for us
than for others who don't travel to
these areas what did the the
circumstances of her killing what did
they tell us about the dangers of war
reporting because my sense is that I you
know when I when I look at the the
details she was killed because she was
from the West she was killed because she
was a woman from the West we don't know
for sure to some extent I would always
say look if you can't do what Anya did
in this particular situation then you
can't you know then you can't travel to
these areas because you know this was
you know convoy during the elections you
know she wasn't all by herself I mean it
was everything about this was so to
speak normal if there is such a thing as
a normal scene Afghanistan and yet it
happens but this is what can happen in
such areas and you know that prior to
going
and she knew that risk okay let's talk
about let's talk about you as a wall
report for a war correspondent at so
you've described yourself a couple of
times already in in the program I've
been a little bit surprised because I
have heard you in the past say no that
is precisely what I am NOT I'm not a war
correspondent a war reporter because I'm
not reporting on combatants and conflict
and military logistics or whatever I'm
reporting on something very different
yeah indeed I mean to some extent at
some point you just accept the time that
people use for the kind of job and so I
accept that it's called war reporter
just I would say indeed you're right I'm
not particularly interested in some of
the military aspect of a wall I don't
write about soldiers I don't go embedded
if there's any way I can avoid it
I'm interested in civilians and how
penetrates an entire society and an area
where civilians
you know women children and young old
men leave were victims of such violence
haunting their area and so that is a
thing I think what I care about is to go
to those people and make them had and
give them a voice what special skills do
you have what what aspect of your
personalities do you have that help
people to to really articulate their
sufferings I'm usually not well dressed
I love food I can sleep well no one I
guess he knew something I would you know
I wouldn't underestimate I would have
just said what no I think in general is
just I don't tend to be scared of
strangers I you have that fearlessness
from your mother I understand yes she
taught it to you or you saw it in her no
you could just see you could just see it
my mother was just very very warm
and open passing and trusted but nobody
would possibly want to harm her what a
wonderful thing to pass on to her
daughter yes you know I feel very very
very grateful for hanging that okay
let's go back to the there is because
this is very sick it's a very serious
thing that we're talking about here when
I before I came in now I wrote down just
sort of um the top my head Kate ad Marie
Colvin Martha Gellhorn I could go on it
was the long list of female war
correspondents war reporters does you
know what what is because the cliche is
that many people will have it something
like somebody like Ernest Hemingway or
what have you
yeah drinking drunk exactly who's I
innocent and divorced how is it
different for women to some extent I
would say I don't put their reflection
that all day long
one is I find an advantage because in
many Islamic countries that are trial
two we have different zones and areas
where only men are only women are
allowed to be I get access to that half
of the population that men don't
necessarily get access to and of course
I can also get then act no access to
their stories and I think they probably
have more trust less scared to speak
about harms and about suffering and
about certain forms of violence and
sexual violence that they had to endure
so just something with sin it's there
it's an advantage then also in some
countries where they don't necessarily
respect their own women I get extra good
treatment because they want to prove
that you know they can treat women well
no I you know I haven't ever experienced
as as a disadvantage
it's rather I would say complicated to
be gay and
to travel to areas where gays are still
criminalized it's so taboos that you
know there aren't even words for that
way to desire love you want we'll talk
about the gayness you know we must yeah
I just like to ask you you're somebody
who's who has taught and thought a lot
about how journalism is done in
situations where massacres are taking
place where perhaps even genocide is
taking place what happens to objectivity
well I'm not a great fan of this myth of
objectivity all of you know the distant
reporter not because I want to be biased
not because I think one should you know
speculate or invent stories of course
not but because I think in war zones
it's very very very difficult to pretend
that you're not affected yourself of
course I'm a human being
of course I'm formed and conditioned by
my background and white I'm not black
I'm very conscious about the fact that
I'm white I'm a female as you've said
you know I'm being perceived as
something actually very often I'm not
even perceived as a female because in
the countries our travel to don't look
the way I look and so it's a you know
I'm I'm a subjective but a hopefully
very reflective reporter and in case of
genocide or war crimes
I have to be with of bias towards human
rights I have to be able to call to give
it a name I mean I have to call it this
is a walk fine I'm glad you said that
yeah I think it's a good anchor for all
journalists to be aware of human
principles of human rights well have
some more I have to have some norm by
which to judge and that's international
human rights absolute
now Carolyn emka has together with the
filmmaker and Jelena macaroni been
involved in the making of a series of
short films about tolerance tolerance
specifically of homosexual transgender
and intergenic old tolerant we are
tolerant set out to turn the whole idea
of Tolerance on its head the verse of
the amnesty Sugerman is off but in
youit's the honest King Maxie the
kendama songs come roxas Elton we have
some of you have an evil spirit on
multitude osakans good phenomenon ozone
vietnam for the modern era not to become
concerns
buddy could be one often okay cooks in
the consumers own fastest us to defend
us a huge tennis the move on you is okay
dear my advice is nice to get from Miami
tells out
I'd like to say something completely
Bernard because it's a serious subject
but the you look I know my feeling is
that you had a lot of fun why are you
making this that's not but no we indeed
had lots of fun I have to say thanks to
angioma corner who directed these spots
no we tremendously enjoyed ourselves
tell me in your own words however what
you were trying to achieve because the
message is quite important well what we
were trying to say it was I mean there's
not just in Germany but all over Europe
there's remaining discrepancy between
the rights of heterosexuals and the
rights of LGBTI and what we wanted to
add to the discourse was something that
would you know of course produce
laughter and have people enjoy watching
these spots but at the same time show
that tolerance and the discourse is
about tolerance is always a symmetrical
tolerance is always regulating a version
it's always of a majority that looks
down and others and you know gave us
that tolerance and I think what we were
very serious about was we don't want to
justify that we're gay or we don't want
to beg for our rights you don't want to
be tolerated
indeed no I want you no respect I you
know I I don't mind you know straight
people I just mind that they think they
can give or not give rights to gays and
so I think that's what we wanted we
wanted to show there's always you know
an asymmetry and we wanted to reverse
this and wanted to subvert a little bit
that discourse on tolerance by having
people change their perspective and
suddenly seeing everything from a
different angle I think they're all all
three of very good films and and you can
watch them on YouTube and they've been
on a bit they've been in the in the
movie theatres here in Berlin I
recommend the people to click onto them
and have a look what kind of impact if
they had uh can you measure it in any
way if you're what sort of responses
they've been well we had lovely I mean
really really had lovely responses I
mean
to say it's three very different they
that they attack sort of different
aspects of the discourse on tolerance of
course where people laugh where people
being irritated of course they also
don't just show the question of
tolerance but of course they show
intolerance
so we also people say oh we're not that
intolerant and I think it's a nice way
to see that you can actually still
interfere in the public sphere even
though this is a topic that has been
addressed and approached you know many
many times and you were you were
involved earlier this year in another
intervention in there in the public
debate in the public discourse when you
you were one of two people who
interviewed Thomas hits Asperger the the
soccer player yes very good soccer
player played for the German national
team played in England played in Italy
played here in Germany and and he came
out he became the highest profile soccer
player in the world to come out yeah at
the time I had a look at the interview
the other day again and the right at the
beginning he says what he wanted to do
was to help to move the public debate in
Germany forward did it the interview the
courage that he had to intervene I think
I mean first of all I think just the act
of coming out on has to say voluntarily
I mean he wasn't hunted down by the
yellow press he himself made that
decision so I think already that was a
huge act just you know just to for young
I think soccer players to see someone
they all admired have the courage to do
it of course I would say of course we
all want a society where it doesn't take
courage of course to some extent you
would want to say so what's the big deal
and yet it is a big deal it is a big
deal on that sports world and I think
what has changed is that the public
response to this was overwhelmingly
positive
I mean Angela Merkel had
speaker comment he's coming out David
Cameron responded and if we remember I
mean there was an English soccer player
many many years ago who did come out
also as in fashion oh yes and that was a
tragic it really was it was a really
really horrible episode so of course we
as journalists also we're really worried
you know and you you you couldn't really
foresee how the public response would be
and so the fact that there was such an
overwhelmingly positive response to this
of course gives hope that you know next
time hopefully and will be someone who's
still actively playing lots of active
female international players play for
Germany have come out just give me a
very very quick answer from what you
know or you don't know from your insider
circles here are their gay players in
the German men's national team I have no
clue ok enough on the subject yeah
Berlin the city where we are
broadcasting from has a host of
excellent theaters one of the most
exciting which this ladies are involved
with is the maxim gorky theatre it's in
what used to be East Berlin and the
theater named for the Russian writer
Maxim Gorky was originally dedicated to
promoting Russian and Soviet theater
these days the focus is very different
as we find out now
charmagne long-haul is the artistic
director of Berlin's maxim gorky theater
since November 2013 she and yen's Helia
have been in charge of the small State
Theatre in the German capital
moving from off theater to a municipal
stage is exciting long off is also the
country's first Turkish German artistic
director she has a new ensemble new
ideas and she's created a space for
everyone in the city whatever their
origins
the ensemble is international it's about
who people are rather than about the
migration stories in their backgrounds
we've decided everyone here has a
background in vibration they're all
vibrating hyperactive and want to get on
stage the theatre mirrored life in the
city when the season opened with
Chekhov's cherry orchard director Newark
on-air Paula
portrayed the Russian rural Gentry as
Berlin partygoers
byungji stop we've got a city with
hundreds of different manures the kind
that develop in the city like this the
political scene the artist students
intellectuals the different communities
and ethnic groups communities Eithne
seen what i want to do is present a
program and tell stories that appeal to
every one of them on Japan
Sherman long Hoff thinks in political
terms she wants to use the theater to
influence people at least a bit but she
can't do that alone
she wants to get the public excited and
attract new audiences ammu is een
recites germany's constitution that got
attention and was one of 32 performances
celebrating the reopening of the maxim
gorky theater the approach seems to be
working
95% of the theater seats are filled
Maxim Gorky theatre it's an exciting
place and we're carrying the report
because you are involved with the
theater and the people who someone yes
what does the somewhat amount to well
I'm a great fan of the program I know
some of the actors who are in the
ensemble of the Gorky
and I know the co-director against hylia
very well he's a good friend of mine and
I know Sherman Lang off of course
nothing they the two together they
really rock the city okay and you're
being very modest about your connection
with the theater because it was R it was
that the theater was completely revamped
and go and took a new start a couple of
months ago and you were the person who
was given the job of holding a sort of a
major keynote address at the function
yeah yes it was interesting I know
because I've read it I wasn't there yeah
tell us what you said I mean really I
have to say the really really funny
thing was when they asked me what do you
like to do the key no they didn't really
say keynote but they said look you know
we would want someone to from the
outside to speak at the opening of the
theater and we would ask you to speak
about what your wishes are you know I
thought Oh fantastic I they actually
asking me to say you know you should
play Beckett
I could imagine what kind of prey I
could wish you know and unfortunate
that's not what impact and no and then I
basically I think it's Sampson spoke as
a Berliner and just what you are yeah
and said I'm deeply deeply moved that
these young actually young an old actors
who who have a background from all over
the world who used to already be at you
know off scene theaters try to go into
the Gorky so that those from the
periphery that they are now in the city
center and what you're talking about is
what is what they call it the theater
post migrant theater can you define that
for me in sort of in German there's this
totally bizarre it's an important
movement in Germany now impact I mean
yes I mean Stuart Hall once said
identity is an you know endless open
question and conversation and to some
extent I think that is what they related
they say yes we have these roots or we
have this family history of you know
parents or grandparents who came to
Germany and yet they also want to
transcendent and they want to work with
these experiences but don't make them
their sole core identity but that sounds
to me because I'm talking to you as the
philosopher now yeah there's been too
little of the Philosopher's on the show
there's been a you know we talked a lot
about the war reporter and the author
the the in this speech you called for
because what you're saying is you know
there's a lot of diversity of human
experience and a lot of it is is now
happening here in Germany which is a
great thing but in in your address as I
understood it you said there is too much
difference and you want more similarity
yes what was the similarity that sounds
almost as though we need to have core
values here in Germany sonica concern
but you know I think what I meant was
that there is a form of discourse on
identity and difference that tends to
sound a little bit too essential istic
and I mean evidently when you you called
or you called talking German and not
I mean the German version is for the
German version of our show here on DW is
called different be storage because I
just wanted to say you know you call it
typically German and you know that that
is you ask what is typical yeah and what
is a real German and was a real my grand
and what's a real Muslim so I what I
think is if you want to be as artists
successful then you have to of course
make reference to these backgrounds and
these identities and yet you know
subvert them transform them and use them
as much material for then artistic and
aesthetic expression and that I think is
what then enables you to also find an
audience that doesn't have that same
background but yet can somehow see some
resemblances or similarities to their
own emotions and lives thank you very
much for those thoughts and thank you
very much in general for sharing your
thoughts with us aus welcome thanks for
having me great stuff that is your lot
with the sometimes controversial always
compelling Caroline emka if you've
enjoyed her company as much as I have
them do come back next week until then
bye bye interest
you